could time have more than one dimension
just as string theory requires more
spatial dimensions that we experienced
couldn't it be possible to have more
time dimensions than we experience I
assume one nice so one time to have more
than one dimension there's nothing
compelling that requires us to think
that but then it does or doesn't that it
does there's nothing compelling us that
requires that we have to think that time
is more than one dimension but if it did
that would just be cool
it is it possible think about so if you
if you go onto one of the time
dimensions then I would ticket a
particular rate for yeah it is for
another dimension it could take at a
different rate and if you go in a
direction that's a hybrid of each of
those two directions it would you would
then hybridize the rate at which your
time unfolds that's no different from
walking you can go north or you can go
east if your lingo north you're not
going east at all
yeah only Galatian are good if you go in
between north you're going a little bit
north yellow you go north northeast yeah
East South receives you're saying there
could be time that's going north and
time to cozies in a setting and then you
could pick a trajectory that gets you a
little bit of one time in a lot more of
another that would just be kind of
interesting move and I don't know quite
how to think about that going forward
this is we're not compelled to do so
[Music]